le rainbow warrior un des plus grands
scandales d'état de la vème république
la sphère porte le nom d'un bateau de
greenpeace à son bord les militants
protestent contre les essais nucléaires
français
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit attaqué le 10
juillet 1985
l'attentât contre un bateau de
l'organisation écologiste greenpeace via
le wan bowker couler mystérieusement
lire dans le port d'auckland en nouvelle
zélande attentat qui a fait une victime
un des membres de l'équipage du bateau
un photographe de greenpeace meurt très
vite les autorités néo zélandaises mène
l'enquêté
un couple de touristes suisses et
arrêter les époux tu ranges en réalité
deux agents secrets français et une
deuxième équipe de la dgse et rechercher
la france son état major et ses
responsables politiques montrent alors
s'engluer dans une spirale du mensonge
à commencer par charles hernu le
ministre de la défense vous avez
démissionné
écoutez c'est votre question est
tellement drôle
il finit par admettre qu'il n'y avait
bien une mission en nouvelle zélande
mais ce qu'il dit c'est qu'elle se
limitait à du renseignement aucun
service
aucune organisation dépendant de mon
ministère n'a reçu l'ordre de commettre
un attentat contre le rainbow warrior le
18 septembre le monde fait des
révélations
il n'y avait pas deux mais trois équipes
de la dgse
c'est cette dernière qui a posé les
bombes alors le 20 septembre le chef des
services secrets limogé le ministre de
la défense démissionne le gouvernement
avoue ce sont des agents de la dgse qui
ont coulé ce bateau et les antes agi sur
ordre c'est le ministre de la défense
qui aurait donné le feu vert et question
2000 est il le véritable responsable de
la sphère au chac riffier pour raison
d'état des années plus tard en 1997
l'ancien chef de la dgse affirme
l'implication du prêt
dans mitterrand disparu depuis un an au
courant des préparatifs naturellement
celui qui m'en avait donné l'ordre dans
cet ailleurs le ministre de la défense
au courant également parce que je l'en
avais fait part dans une audience
personnel et direct
le président mitterrand à qui j'en avais
parlé le 15 mai seuls les faux époux tu
ranges ont été condamnés dix ans de
réclusion
ni le chef des services secrets ni le
ministre de la défense n'ont été
inquiétés et encore moins le président
de la république
[Musique]